okay so next up is uranium hair which is
my favorite actinide it's the one I
handle in the lab it's also the
boogeyman of the periodic table I think
soon as you say uranium to people people
start going not sure about that uranium
is the basis of much of nuclear power
and it exists in two isotopes that's two
atoms of different weight there's
uranium 238 which is the most abundant
one and the other uranium 235 which is
the one which when irradiated with
neutrons will split in half and release
nuclear energy and a lot of work has
been done or was done during the Second
World War on the separation of these
isotopes of uranium and including the
construction of the biggest mass
spectrometers that had ever been made
and fortunately the separation of
uranium isotopes is really very
difficult which is why it is only very
large and rich countries have been able
to afford to make nuclear weapons but
it's actually really interesting element
to deal with it's got a wide variety of
oxidation states and if you use it in
its depleted form it's actually
relatively safe to handle in the
laboratory now depleted material only
contains a very small quantity of fizzle
uranium which is used in bombs and
nuclear reactors about point2 of a
percent it actually means that the
problem with handling depleted uranium
is not the radioactivity although you
have to make provision for this the real
problem is it's highly poisonous and
about half a gram would kill you in a
very short period of time because it
attacks your liver very effectively so
once you've removed the uranium-235
you're still left with very large amount
99 points more than ninety-nine percent
of the mass of your original uranium is
uranium 238 in which you have removed
most but not all of the uranium 235 and
this is so-called depleted uranium which
is some of the densest
you can get and so it is used where you
want something very heavy that's not too
large so for example it's used in the
counterweights that people put in
aeroplanes in liners in large aeroplanes
to balance the plane because you can use
of it takes up in the small volume of
space it is also used in a number of
weapons because you can get a very heavy
bullet or shell for armor-piercing but
it has the rather unfortunate property
as a metal that if you hit it very hard
and suddenly it can shatter into very
small pieces which can then react with
the air and so this is why that depleted
uranium munitions can then cause quite a
lot of pollution because it can cause
some radioactivity when it blows apart
uranium turnings just look like any of
the metal it's just silvery shiny
there's bits of it which is slightly
darkened where it's reacted with the air
and oxidized the halides are quite
interesting if you make a uranium
tetrachloride it's bright green sort of
emerald green color is really beautiful
to look at and if you make what's call
you and I'll dichloride which is uo 2 CL
2 it's bright yellow never ever allow
uranium out of a flask of because if
you're in a position to smell it you're
in a position to inhale it and that's
where the damage will be done we have to
keep it safe and secure in a safe and we
have to fill out huge amounts of
paperwork many a forest has been chopped
down for this paperwork um sure but it's
all very important because you have to
be certain that when you're handling you
depleted uranium compounds that you're
not going to end up poisoning anybody
and you're not going to end up going
radioactive compounds all over the place
so we have log books and we have to
record how much we use and when and how
we dispose of it we have detectives
which we have to sweep the lab well a
lot of people usually start off with I
imagine you glow in the dark which if I
could do that I'd have passed away a
long time before that point yeah it's
the boogeyman thing again a lot of
people are quite
sort of surprised and you know so
shocked to hear that your you're
handling this stuff but actually it's
just like most of the chemicals in the
periodic table and once you get past the
boogeyman image of it it's actually a
very interesting element to work with